لعدة أشهر ، كان RSV يسيطر على الولايات المتحدة حيث
ارتفعت الحالات ، كانت بعض مستشفيات الأطفال
غارقة ، لكن أحدث بيانات CDC
تظهر أن الفيروس قد بلغ ذروته في الولايات المتحدة
RSV منخفض وهذا أمر جيد والآن هناك
علاج محتمل في معركتنا ضد
حالات RSV المستقبلية عند الرضع  تقوم إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية (FDA)
بمراجعة بالقرب من سيفاماب وهو
جسم مضاد طويل المفعول للوقاية من
التهابات الجهاز التنفسي السفلي التي
يسببها الفيروس ، وسيتم إعطاء أول جسم مضاد من نوعه
كجرعة واحدة
في بيان للشركات التي
قالت إن العلاج التنموي قد أشارت إليه إدارة الغذاء والدواء.
ستعمل على تسريع
مراجعتها ويمكن أن تحدث الموافقة في
وقت ما من هذا الصيف ، مضيفًا أنه إذا تمت الموافقة ،
نعتقد أنه قريب من سيفوماب ، فقد يغير
نهج المجتمع الطبي
للوقاية من RSV والرضع ، ونحن
ملتزمون بالعمل مع إدارة الغذاء والدواء
لدعم إكمال المراجعة في
أسرع وقت ممكن  وجدت بيانات من تجربة المرحلة 3
المنشورة في مجلة New England
Journal of Medicine أن عدوى
RSV تتطلب العناية الطبية  حدث في
1.2 في المائة من الأطفال الذين تلقوا
العلاج مقارنة بخمسة في المائة من
الأطفال الذين تلقوا العلاج الوهمي ، مما يعني أن
العلاج أكثر من 74 فعالًا
ولم يتم تحديد مخاوف تتعلق بالسلامة
الصحية ، أنا ماندي غايثر